yo what's going on guys crispy flakes
here of bleacher report and for today's
video we are checking out ranking the 10
worst signings of the 2021 nba free
agency so this is back from august 11th
uh it's a real fun opportunity to kind
of look back and see what we were
thinking at the time and see you know
how things have kind of played out
because nobody's a fortune teller nobody
can predict exactly how things are gonna
happen and uh really we can only use
history as a metric to see what the
future is going to be like uh but also
it's important to know too that you know
a bad contract does not always mean a
bad player and sometimes that player
makes the most of the contract situation
and the uh team that they're on now
right man so yes uh before we get going
on today's video if you guys don't mind
dropping that like just because you know
nobody's a fortune teller so it's hard
to really predict how things are going
to play out so yeah it's important to
know this is all for good fun and uh
just kind of like seeing what our
opinions were like at the time right man
so let's go ahead and get going on this
starting with number 10 we got cp3 of
the phoenix sun so
you know when chris paul signed that
four-year 120 million dollar contract um
that was after a finals run right so you
know this isn't the circumstance where
chris paul's like a bad player that got
120 million dollars um i think that this
actually still holds up pretty well
because yes in the short term of things
chris paul and the phoenix suns can very
well win a championship but you know you
could hear three or four of that
contract where you owe 60 million
dollars to a 38 year old injury-prone
point guard um that can be a very scary
thing right and even in the moment like
chris paul is going gonna be out for
about two months now so i mean uh cp3
went healthy an all-star player but
eventually filer time does catch up to
everybody and i hope this is not the
beginning of that but uh yeah i can see
why this contract would not be the
greatest in a few seasons from now not
on the short term though man i'm really
hoping the phoenix suns can pull the
championship because cp3 definitely
deserves a ring uh next up we got kyle
lowry to the miami heat and this was on
a three-year
85 million dollar contract kind of the
same song and dance as chris paul in
this case where in the short term of
things you know kyle lowry was brought
in
to help the miami heat get to the nba
finals you have him with bam and jimmy
butler and tyler hero when those guys
are all healthy it's one of the most
dangerous teams in the nba but another
case where he's an older point guard so
you know once that third year hits it
could be a bad contract right um so yeah
no uh no issues with this one uh
whatsoever at all um next up we got
daniel tys of the houston rockets okay
so the rocket situation was kind of
weird because going into the season you
know it was this mix of they had guys
like christian wood who wanted to
obviously win some basketball games now
you got kevin porter jalen green a lot
of excitement there uh daniel tyce was
brought to be like this you know kind of
like a combo forward you might say a guy
that can play the power forward position
the center position um
but playing simple daniel tyce just
wasn't really great and he's on the
boston celtics again so shout out to him
he's on his former team with a nice
contract but at the time this was a very
bad contract signing and it still is um
next up we got zach collins of the san
antonio spurs so this one still confuses
me three years 22 million dollars um
yeah because he was on the portland
trail blazers had some injury issues
over there
i think he's played a total of like 16
or 17 games in the past two seasons
um i think he just started playing for
the spurs again so this one the
verdict's still out on it but uh we'll
kind of see i mean when he is healthy
zach collins is actually one of the
better like defensive bigs in the nba
can stretch the floor a little bit so
we'll see if he can uh you know earn
that 22 million dollars over the course
of the next three seasons with the spurs
um next up we got duncan robinson the
miami this is a five-year 90 million
dollar contract man and duncan robinson
at the time
he deserved that money like there's just
the way that he moves without the
basketball gets himself over for that
three-point shot when that three-point
shot is going in he's a dangerous player
the issue is that that's what he does
best and this season for the miami heat
since he got that contract he's been
really bad like he's been shooting i
believe um
i don't know man there was a point where
he was shooting like
mid to high 20 within the three-point
shot i think over the course of like the
past 10 games he's shooting like 33 from
three which i mean you know for a guy
that's known as the sharpshooter that's
not great so yeah definitely uh this
contract is not aging very good in the
early you know run of things but over
the course of the you know five seasons
we know dunk robson is capable of
three-point shots so we'll see if he can
start you know getting out of that
shooting slump a little bit a lot of
it's just mental so hopefully he bounces
back from that
number five we got kelly olynyk of the
detroit pistons on a three or 37 million
dollar contract so you know back when
the pistons signed kelly olynyk i mean
let's call it like it is you know
detroit's not really a huge free agent
destination um to start the season
olynyk was actually playing really solid
for that second unit for the pistons
like he was somebody that they were
really running the offense through uh
then he got injured and since he's been
back he's been atrocious like just
shooting poorly just not moving the same
and i think it's a case where you know
olynyk might get shut down before the
season's over with like just get this
guy healthy he can come back next season
with the pistons and be that same role
as a six man or i still think it's a
very tradable contract um just because
the way we know he's capable of playing
like he really did show something to
start the season kind of like mason
plumley did last year after the detroit
pistons before getting a nice contract
with the charlotte horizon
yeah we'll see if he's on the season or
on the team next season but
i don't know a lot of this is gonna be
about getting healthy and stuff like
that uh next up we got devonte graham of
the pelicans this is still a very bad
contract but situationally speaking
because devante was brought to the team
to replace lonzo ball lonzo ball was not
coming back to the pelicans and i think
that the way that devante was meant to
be utilized in the pelicans offense was
that i kind of envisioned it as him
being like the mario chalmers you know
back when there was like lebron marvel
chummers in the miami heat like chalmers
was a point guard that would just be
open to shoot threes and stuff like that
and you know having like lebron out
there that would allow marvel charmers
to be open to those type of shots uh
same case of the pelicans where we all
thought zion was hopefully gonna play
this season and be a guy that you know
was gonna require double teams even
triple teams at times and leave guys
like davonte grant wide open for that
shot the issue is that when
devonta i'm sorry when zion's not
playing that means there's more
responsibility on devonta graham to be
more of a shock creator and really just
more focus point of the opposing team's
defense and um that's just not really
who he is like even when he was on the
charlotte hornets um he was a very
inefficient player and that's really
aging to be that type of player right
now so i still think this one could get
better if zion comes back fully
committed to the team everything like
that you know they're still a good place
but playing simple devontae was never
going to replace what lonzo ball could
do anyway um i'm just hoping he can get
better because if not you know when he
was on the hornets he was on the minimum
contract when he was playing 47 million
dollars to the numbers he puts up right
now uh very bad uh next up we got evan
fournier for the new york knicks four
years of 78 million dollars so initially
when they signed evan fournier i
actually thought it was a pretty good
contract it's about 17 million dollars a
season and you know not so much on the
boston celtics but going back to like
the orlando magic days he was around
like a 17 18 point three game score um
he was brought to the knicks as a guy
that was supposed to take some pressure
off julius randle alongside with kemba
walker and that's just not really been
the case i mean evan fournier is a solid
shooting guard but uh at four years 78
million dollars now uh once you get a
contract that i don't think is going to
get any better in time unless you know
we can really get a shot together and
everything uh number two we got jared
allen to the cleveland cavaliers so this
one five years 100 million dollars
i don't think this is an argument of uh
him not being worth that money
i think at the time though you know they
had laurie marketing they brought on
evan mobley and then you signed out to
that contract he's like okay like who's
gonna be the bench player uh little did
we know um jared allen and evan mobley
works perfectly as a front court and a
lot of that is attuned to evan mobley's
early on skill set i mean evan mobley
looks like a guy that's been the nba for
five or six years the way that he can
just move without the basketball and
play alongside jared allen and
compliment him you know not only
offensively but defensively speaking
like it makes jared allen's contract so
much better because yes if mobley came
in and kind of had like a james weisman
start where he definitely played like a
rookie um
then it might have been like a weird
kind of combo because you probably
couldn't play jared and evan mobley
together but a lot of this is just also
darry's garland his step step up as a
leader for this team and everything like
that and getting the most out of his
players man so yeah shout out to jared
allen shout out to cleveland cavaliers
on this one right here um it turned out
to be a fantastic contract for the
cavaliers they got themselves i'm an
all-star for the foreseeable future and
then number one we have demar derozan
the chicago bulls on a three-year 85
million dollar contract so we were all
in the same mindset at the time of this
one where uh
you know the bulls they got lounge of
the ball they got voucher [ __ ] you know
uh last year the trade deadline and then
they signed demar derozan and you know
there wasn't really a lot of big trades
going on at the time uh the free agent
signings last year they were kind it was
kind of a a lower
kind of uh talent pool so i mean demar
derozan was one of the best players out
there the thing about him is that he
wasn't the san antonio spurs and in that
spur system the team was not built
correctly around him it was a very
slower style um a basketball just
because look at greg popovich is the
head coach like popovich was not gonna
switch up his system this way in his nba
coaching career so it was just kind of
slow and you know jonte murray and like
uh kelden johnson just not a great fits
around demar derozan but demar has
always been a bucket so once he went to
that bulls team you know he was always
putting up stats even going on the spurs
but did not lead to w so it's like okay
the bulls are getting this guy that we
know can put up numbers but it's really
gonna lead into anything and i think a
lot of that just comes down to um just
all the pieces and the vision of the
chicago
management came together perfectly and
uh yeah the team is built perfectly so
while these were viewed upon as bad
contracts at the time uh some of these
obviously are still really bad contracts
but i think a lot of it too was just
like what we were looking at at the time
and i think demar derozan man like
nobody nobody nobody could have
predicted how great an mvp calibris he
could have been for this bulls team and
uh if you did predict that you should
probably go play the lottery or
something like that because it's insane
so yeah um
this is really fun to check out right
here i i think when it comes down to it
though um it's just really hard to
really know how exactly a player is
going to fit in so
yeah this is really fun to look at
though thank you guys all so much for
watching and peace out my friends